der magellan strom droht mit unserer
galaxie zu kollidieren ein gewaltiger
gasstrom der uns viel näher ist als
bisher angenommen
genau das haben us wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler jetzt herausgefunden
und so droht unserer heimat galaxie
möglicherweise eine koalition mit diesem
gigantischen bogen aus sternen und gas
und eine andere kollision mit unserer
galaxie hat dagegen bereits begonnen
klicks um science and future gegen drei
mal pro woche spannende science videos
aber nicht den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
dass es diesen ungewöhnlichen strom aus
gas zwischen der milchstraße und den
beiden magellanschen wolken gibt das ist
der fachwelt schon lange bekannt doch
bislang wusste man nicht wie nah uns
dieser sogenannte magische strom
wirklich ist eine aktuelle studie
offenbart jetzt die große überraschung
fünf mal näher als gedacht könnte uns
dieser riesige gasstrom wirklich sein
möglicherweise eine gefahr für unsere
heimatgalaxie die milchstraße
denn das gas könnte mit ihrem halo also
dem halo unserer galaxie wechselwirken
und später könnte sogar zu einer
gewaltigen kollision kommen genau davor
warnen jetzt die us fachleute in ihrer
aktuellen studie alle spannenden infos
zu diesen neuen spektakulären
erkenntnissen gibt es jetzt hier bei
klicks und science in future die
milchstraße die galaxie in der wir leben
ihr durchmesser beträgt unglaubliche 100
tausend lichtjahre und sie setzt sich
aus bis zu 200 milliarden sternen
zusammen es handelt sich um eine
spiralgalaxie fachleute haben sie unter
anderem deswegen noch längst nicht im
detail verstanden denn ihre gestalt
macht es äußerst kompliziert die
außenbereiche der milchstraße genauer zu
analysieren
daher sind die zusammensetzung der
milchstraße und auch die ausdehnung
ihres halos bisher nur teilweise
erforscht mit dem begriff halo meinen
fachleute das was sich rings um die
scheibe die meist als die eigentliche
galaxie betrachtet wird befindet es
handelt sich um eine annähernd
sphärische kugelförmige region in der
kugelsternhaufen und stern ströme ihren
platz haben genauso wie eine menge an
gas plasma und wohl auch die mysteriöse
dunkle materie sind im halo von galaxien
zu finden als das gehört also zum
sogenannten gravitative einzugsgebiet
einer galaxie bei dem halo handelt es
sich also um eine art diffuse hülle
immer wieder werden neue studien
veröffentlicht die überraschende
erkenntnisse über unsere heimatgalaxie
offenbar so konnte mit der hilfe des
röntgenteleskop xmm erst vor kurzem
festgestellt werden dass der halo der
milchstraße wohl heißer und eisen ärmer
ist als bislang angenommen
dazu die us-wissenschaftlerin samantha
burke von der yale university sie
berichtet die riesigen halos und
galaxien zu verstehen ist enorm wichtig
denn diese reserve enthalten den
rohstoff für künftige stern bildung in
der galaxie aber auch die ausströme von
vergangenen ereignissen wie supernovae
der halo ist daher voller informationen
über die vergangenheit und zukunft einer
galaxie zudem verrät die ausdehnung des
halo einiges über die gravitative
einflusssphäre einer galaxie doch jetzt
berichtet eine aktuelle studie
spektakuläre erkenntnisse über die
nachbarschaft unserer galaxie konkret
geht es um den sogenannten magischen
strom
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
rätseln schon seit vielen jahren wie
dieser gas aus strom entstanden sein
könnte klar ist allerdings dass uns
dieses gas einige hinweise auf die
geschichte den ursprung und das
schicksal der großen und der kleinen
magellanschen wolke geben dabei handelt
es sich um die nächsten beiden nachbarn
unserer milchstraße nicht nur die
milchstraße sondern eben auch die
magellanschen wolken sind in ihrer
vergangenheit wohl mit kleineren
zwerggalaxien kollidiert vor drei jahren
hatte ein us forschungsteam
herausgefunden dass die magellanschen
wolken möglicherweise einmal teil einer
dreiergruppe von zwerggalaxien gewesen
sein könnten doch vor rund 3 bis 5
milliarden jahren war die dritte galaxie
wohnen mit der magellanschen wolke
kollidiert und zerstört worden hinweise
darauf liefert nicht nur eine gruppe
verkehrt herum kreisender sterne in der
großen magellanschen wolke sondern auch
ein mysteriöser ausbruch der stern
bildung zum möglichen zeitpunkt dieser
kollision eine spannende geschichte also
die die nachbarn bislang miteinander
erlebt haben sie stehen also in enger
wechselwirkung
voneinander und zudem auch mit unserer
heimatgalaxie der milchstraße die
schwerkraft wechselwirkung führt nach
ansicht von astronomen gastronomen
weltweit dazu dass es immer wieder
diebstähle gab die nachbarn klauten sich
gegenseitig nicht nur gas sondern auch
sterne der marianische strom aus gas und
stern verbindet die beiden wollten
miteinander und ist fast so lang wie die
milchstraße sein ursprung und auch sein
alter bleiben bis heute rätselhaft dazu
sagt der us astronom scott lucchini der
ursprung des marianischen stroms ist
seit rund 50 jahren ein rätsel zwei
mögliche entstehung thesen wurden
bislang diskutiert wurde der strom etwa
durch gas erzeugt das aus den galaxien
herausgerissen wurde als sie durch den
halo unserer milchstraße wanderten oder
entstand der strom etwa durch die
gezeitenkräfte der milchstraße
forschungsteams konnten in der
vergangenheit zeigen dass der markante
strom nicht nur älter sondern auch
länger ist als gedacht möglicherweise
hat er das sogar ein stolzes alter von
zweieinhalb milliarden jahr aktuelle
modellsimulationen von us-forschern
können jetzt vielleicht auch weitere
bisher ungelöste rätsel um den mangel an
strom klären dazu nahmen sie neuere
daten der magellanschen wolken genauer
ins visier diese daten weisen darauf hin
dass die beiden magellanschen wolken von
einer art corona aus warmen ionisiertes
gas umgeben sind dazu schreibt das
forschungsteam zitat zusammen mit dem
heißen zug kommen galaktischen medium
der milchstraße spielen die
hydrodynamischen effekte dieser corona
eine signifikante rolle für die
vergangenen bewegungen der beiden kurze
erklärung dass zur com galaktische
medium ist nichts anderes als dass halo
die hülle der milchstraße die ausgasen
und plasma besteht hier sind nicht nur
kugelsternhaufen und stern ströme zu
finden astronomen astronomen gehen davon
aus dass es sich dabei um eine art
rohstoffreserven für die neue stern
bildung handelt und tatsächlich gab es
eine überraschung für die fachleute als
sie die corona in die simulation
einfügten lautes forschungsteams ändert
sich dadurch die ganze orbitale
geschichte in der woche demnach haben
sich die beiden zwerggalaxien vor rund
1,4 milliarden angenähert dabei wurde
sehr viel material aus der kleineren der
beiden wolken herausgerissen material
für den magellanschen strom die
aktuellen simulationen unterscheiden sie
enorm von den modellen die bislang
aufgestellt worden waren denn in der
aktuellen studie bewegt sich die kleinen
magellanschen wolken plötzlich gegen den
uhrzeigersinn an der großen nachbarn
vorbei und so zeigt der gasstrom ebenso
plötzlich nicht mehr von den wolken und
der milchstraße weg dazu heißt es in der
aktuellen studie unsere rekonstruktion
resultiert in einem auf und
zugerichteten strom denn bis auf
65.000 lichtjahre an die sonne
herankommt also das ist schon verdammt
hat die ausrichtung des gasstrom system
nach also ganz anders als bislang
gedacht und das hat weitere folgen der
gigantische bogen aussterben und gas
könnte uns demnach also deutlich näher
sein als bislang angenommen und zwar bis
zu fünfmal mehr der strom liegt laut der
us astronomen astronomen fast schon am
außenrand der milchstraße und das hat
folgen zum einen könnten seine sterne
direkt von uns beobachtet werden zum
anderen könnte somit auch der steckbrief
des magellanschen stroms umgeschrieben
werden denn auch in bezug auf seine
dichte und masse könnten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
bislang falsch gelegen haben lediglich
ein fünftel der bisher geschätzten masse
hält das forschungsteam nun für
realistisch dazu der usa um andrew fox
seiner studie beteiligt war durch die
veränderte entfernung müssen nun auch
einige merkmale reduziert werden das
betrifft unter anderem auch die
lebensdauer des magellanschen stroms die
den neuen erkenntnissen zufolge
dramatisch kurzer sein könnte als
bislang vermutet die neuen erkenntnisse
haben also auch auswirkungen auf die
zukunft des stroms und nicht nur das
auch für unsere heimatgalaxie die
milchstraße könnte das konsequenzen
haben denn es droht eine gewaltige
kollision zwischen dem riesigen bogen
aus gas und sternen mit der milchstraße
nach ansicht der forschen steht uns das
allerdings erst in rund 50 millionen
jahren bevor doch bereits deutlich
früher könnte es zur auswirkung kommt
dann nämlich wenn das gas mit dem halo
unserer galaxie wechselwirkt dazu die
einschätzung des forschungsteams der
magellansche strom könnte aufgrund
seines währungs winkel sogar direkt mit
der scheibe der milchstraße kollidiert
eine andere kollision ist übrigens
bereits in vollem gange kollisionen
unserer milchstraße mit der andromeda
galaxie ugc begonnen hier gibt es
bereits die ersten beobachtungen
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran